golden knights are on the road tonight
with the showdown that's right vegas is
coming off of two straight
losses but was given a dose of some good
news we've got john treach in studio for
us hey john
yeah we will start with a reminder that
not all goaltender saves are created
equally
today the golden knights announced that
mark andre fleury had a false
positive covent test he is back with the
team healthy
and the virus had a breakaway and was
denied it is unlikely flurry will be in
net tonight as he has not worked
out with the team in a couple of days
but he is on the available roster oscar
dance
is the likely starter in net and he will
have his hands full the saint louis
blues are a powerful stanley cup
contender and
hungry to overtake the knights in the
division standings the intensity will be
cranked up under the gateway arch
tonight
you know just deal with it and uh and
next man up if that's the case and and
uh find a way to get a win really big
games you know
uh for a couple reasons obviously
because uh this is a good team
and you know probably um you know up
there with us and colorado's the top
teams in the in the division and
we're coming off two losses that um were
big games for us and we didn't play the
way we wanted to so
these are you know two big bounce back
games but also two
big standing games the last time vegas
played st
louis the entire coaching staff was
quarantined so this is really no big
deal when it comes to adversity the
blues and knights will drop the puck
tonight at 5 pm
vegas is holding on to a one point lead
in the nhl west
division